[Music]
your show is one of the best new show
thank you so much he blows me away thank
you I am so very proud to be a part of
it yeah it's an any people but more
important congratulations you had a baby
was it three months I did baby boys
three months what's interesting you were
shooting true detective
while you were pregnant I was I was I
didn't actually wrap the show until I
was about five months pregnant but and I
didn't tell anybody anybody I didn't I
didn't tell anybody because I just I
wanted to concentrate on the work I
didn't want to be distract it or
anything like that and but I honestly I
think it worked to my benefit because
the show actually spans 20 years
so as my ass was getting bigger I was
getting older like I sort of feel like
they were all being very nice to me but
I was gaining weight as like each like
we could come down to see like a couple
of pounds heavier and their costume
designers like okay so you need and we
need to size up in the pants I'm like
yeah yeah yeah I think they just thought
I was being method they just thought
that you were like the most amazing be
dedicated I'm aging I must yes I'm gonna
concentrate now and grow my ass it did
so so finally you tell them you tell
them when you're wrapping my last day
that hey guess what surprised I'm
helpful
I was I was about five and a half months
pregnant that way yeah yeah they were
all shocked what was I in Matthew
McConaughey is your co-stars what was
his reaction alright alright alright
reaction to everything
here's your cheeseburger alright
look the moon you have it's such a great
cast you you're in this with with
Matthew McConaughey and Woody Harrelson
and you're shooting this thing in New
Orleans and so I think about you got
those guys who are legends they don't
you know they know how to have a good
time and they're in Ireland and you're
pregnant yeah exactly they must be going
out every night yeah and you were having
what low-crime it was kind of
disappointing as it was kind of torture
you know you're in this amazing city you
can go out and have a good time and yeah
these guys I remember Willie Nelson was
in town for Jazz Fest and they were
having a poker game and they're like
Michelle why don't you come on you know
to the poker and I was I was pregnant
and I couldn't I couldn't go because I
knew I wasn't gonna walk out of there
sober oh you know even if I'd have
anything you know what you're saying
doctors say you can't play em Willie
Nelson Woody Harrelson Matthew
McConaughey yeah yeah just go to discos
it's gonna go to bed just do it yeah
exactly